yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing tour heat to power complicated
complicated play them once don't
remember the game so go for scotch four
nights yeah the game count is right
never got the Scotch played against you
now it's found the book
you start h3 actually there was a bit
early
yeah it doesn't really Queen a3 is I
think not Terra would still not what the
doctor ordered
it takes it I don't mind dad queen is
some night stick position now on a dark
square night a for Queen defaults nice
to get this in
okay so put it here
maybe Queen a5 actually hmm okay I can
play c3 and next night c5 probably
95 immediately he's got work to be
formed the problem is that it's 97
yeah okay so queen d4 wasn't so great
I don't have any really great square C 3
or C 5 we will take a form
maybe just c5 now for black
okay let's push him back Wow he does not
want to go back but hmm
Queen g3 then rogue age five what is
that to the point or what it's really
odd
it's really hard but I cannot really use
it home
Wow it's very complicated here this
position technically speaking
c4 Bishop b2 I can also I have rupees
six as an idea in this position but I
think just I forego Bobby - he might
have 94 okay now before 95 is an idea if
I can get that in it would be nice okay
I mean now d4 is weak again for the
Queen
we'll see like d4 I've opened everything
maybe could be an idea
the strategic take windey 4 would be
really great if I can get it in 94 at c5
coming
tonight if for what's the deal here
[Music]
cannot go up she won which is kind of
annoying
could have taken eight seven I'm not
sure why I didn't do that I've got no
time and the position is complete chaos
now Jesus save me I simply don't play
well it's just what it is
I completely outplayed the opponents and
then I'm playing some nonsense like in
this game this is really very bad like
the position 10 moves before the end of
the game is just winning like here here
white is just winning after 95 oh I'm
losing with Bishop h3 okay and then I'm
winning like here or something I mean
just it's just not possible possibly
good for black you have the rook here
you have weaknesses all over the place
so be four wins okay yeah that still
look good but Queen c7 is good a good
defensive try I have I don't have many
defenders that's true
before g5 four F four wins okay yeah
that nighty for bida F for business got
really dangerous should do you want yeah
I mean I'm and I don't think that my
intuition is wrong that white should be
clearly better here or winning but it
requires some sort of precision okay
Bishop age three that wasn't exactly
easy to say that this way let this wins
I went here and now I'm and he sees it
all Here I am ever had a look at seven
of caution I drew k7 because of the
background here I'm winning and they had
Queen a7 yeah I was I'm completely
losing somehow my nerve and hear me now
case III is hanging now and some how
things work him yeah it's not a game
that I can I should lose really Queenie
focus was not great maybe somehow Queen
deform
that's a funny statistics
okay now black is getting now it gets
adjusted I was saying I cannot be that
he played like an engine and that would
be a weird engine between age five yeah
[Music]
95 I would have liked that but I thought
worked before is good I see four is a
good move you know not within my powers
yeah I was quite happy with this
really surprised it's supposed to be
okay for book it said really so
dangerous this counterplay without the
Queen it doesn't look so dangerous and
like this is really not great
this whole configuration you're on the
Queen side but the engine does not
relieve doesn't really agree it's not so
easy to defend like move by move based
here near page for chief for Queen
sister then maybe it's got enough
counter play I think it's really Audia
to put the rope here really hard not
playing well and the time gets down at
least I mean you know I mean I didn't
maybe understand the position correctly
but I should not blunder blunder or all
those moves like here your age form
yes Knight f4 or whoopsie - if I go g3
it's still opposition yeah okay thanks
for watching